he's out of the race Boris Johnson never
officially entered but the prospect of
his return to Downing Street has
dominated this latest leadership contest
last night one of his team broke the
news outside what had become Campaign
Headquarters he's doing things in the
country's interest he's a great match
statement Boyce Johnson insisted that he
that he did have the numbers to win but
he said in the course of the last few
days I have sadly come to the conclusion
that this would simply not be the right
thing to do you can't govern effectively
unless you have a United party in
Parliament he added I believe I have
much more to offer but I'm afraid that
this is simply not the right time
that leaves the way clear for his rival
Rishi sunak always the front runner with
conservative MPS now looking likely to
become the next prime minister last
night he tweeted Boris Johnson delivered
brexit and the great vaccine rollout he
led our country through some of the
toughest challenges we have ever faced
and then took on Putin and his barbaric
war in Ukraine we will always be
grateful to him for that although he has
decided not to run for PM again I truly
hope he continues to contribute to
public life at home and abroad
but there's one more candidate he needs
to beat penny mordent has struggled to
be seen in this race now there are many
more votes up for grabs could she make
the ballot as well yesterday she was
insisting she's still a serious
Contender what this country needs is a
fresh face someone that can unite the
conservative party and get things to
work in this country
Boris Johnson's departure has cast a
shadow over this contest but today
attention turns to the two that remain
and who will take over at number 10 Liz
Bates Sky News Westminster